I'm very happy that you could be here today Jared,
because today is, in fact, your birthday.
(audience claps and cheers)
And uh,
you guys have a tradition on your birthday
of celebrating in a certain way.
(laughs)
Yeah.
Want to tell us what that is?
We streak.
(audience cheering)
That's not, that's, no, that's not really what we do.
Yeah, technically it's usually the next day,
because our birthday we've had too much to drink.
You drink, you get together and you drink.
(laughs) On our birthday.
When the show first started, we used to
sneak kegs into each other's trailers.
(audience laughs)
[Jared] True story.
Warner Brothers, don't listen.
(audience laughs)
When we were done, when we were done filming.
As the years got on, then the kegs became half kegs,
and then they became the little, you know the little
five liter Heineken kegs.
Oh yeah, yeah.
And then it just became embarrassing, it was maybe a beer,
and now I don't think its any, it's like,
[Jared] We'll have a beer this weekend.
We just need some sleep.
Well, Jared, I wanna tell you that, it's nice,
Jensen has arranged a special surprise
for you in honor of your birthday.
(audience cheers and claps)
Bring those out here, should we do that right now?
Oh, here we go, we have a big ...
(audience laughs and claps)
Yeah.
Well ...
(audience claps)
That's the best ...
Yeah.
Now, you see how he tested that out?
Because traditionally it's a keg stand.
Yeah.
Which, if you're only in a fraternity, is okay to do.
Right.
Or, if you're on the Conan O'Brien Show.
Yeah.
(audience claps and cheers)
Do you need help here?
I think I'm mic'd into my uh ...
Now, I will preface this by saying that
my family and I are opening up a craft brewery in Austin,
at the end of the summer.
This is the very first keg ...
Wait a minute!
Ever kegged, and was driven out from Austin, Texas.
I thought this was a ...
(audience claps and cheers)
You need help here?
Yeah, I got that, yeah.
Alright.
I thought this was a stupid stunt, now it's just a plug.
Yeah.
(audience laughs)
[Conan] Alright, here we go.
(audience cheers)
This is good.
We all good, give me a nod?
We done?
(Conan laughs and audience cheers)